cinq ans je crois que vous avez été vous
avez une invitation pour le trail
rabah-noël directement à domicile
notre père noël au chocolat a frappé
fort
regardez
[Musique]
michel jasmin pour six à l'image des
francas le minage vous croyez que je
vais ouvrir cette boîte devant des
caméras venant tpp alors vous mettez
mais alors un doigt dans le cul mes
propos ou vrai que je vais regarder de
loin non mais les mecs arrêtez
et pour vous donner les meilleurs je
vous reviens pas cette boîte
[Musique]
c'est encore jamais de petit
pensez vous que tu avais
[Musique]
owen van natta
et
bon oui bonjour madame j'ai un coulis à
vous livrez vous êtes vous d'accord
bassolé merci
[Musique]
sinon
non mais c'est quoi
[Musique]
bon bah tiens c'est parfait bon
vraiment vous étiez m'avoir tiens tiens
tu as à tarbes à hanouna tu m'auras pas
cette fois aller
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]